now that is very interesting remembering
the mark Fergus wrote the script for
things like Iron Man so why do I mention
that well bringing back a franchise like
Stargate is going to be a massive
challenge bringing back Iron Man the way
they did was similarly a huge challenge
how do you get the exact tone that you
need to be able to hit the bullseye with
a movie like this Stargate the
challenges are what's happened in the
last 15 years how much information do we
share immediately and how much do we
hold back for a later movie later Series
where do we set it how do we set it what
do we bring from the original through do
we bring a couple of cast members
through do we bring sets back etc etc
what do we change to make it interesting
and new but still feeling like stargame
and what do we keep the same getting
this right is going to be so important